yeah yeah so I'm not I still
procrastinate but I have like I went
through this big like self-improvement
phase and so yeah if like really read a
lot about how to not procrastinate so
there's this like there's a famous paper
that has this like equation of
procrastination and it basically says
like yeah so there's like there's like
four four elements of cross nation ever
had problems with your Mac bunch of
garbage making it unbearable to use
maybe it's time for a clean no not like
that
[Music]
nope that's not it either definitely not
that you've given up don't worry I got
just the thing for you presenting
CleanMyMac X by Mac Paul our sponsor for
today
finally a legit mac cleaning app that
actually does what it says
instead of putting even more viruses on
your computer so legit with all these
different features you can deep clean
your Mac in so many ways it will make
your Mac as good as new
the UI is beautiful so sleek makes me
want to clean everyday you can clean up
speed up and protect your Mac with this
app that's how powerful this tool is
honestly this app should be the first
app you install on any Mac so you can
monitor apps or files that don't spark
joy and annihilate them many condo-style
hey Joma how's your Mac doing aren't you
happy you installed CleanMyMac X great
find out more about clean my Mac X and
download the free trial for free with
the link in the description below so
yeah so I like how you you know study
using likely coder shad yeah stuff like
that but what about in general because I
come I heard that you graduate high
school pretty early right yeah I I
skipped like a total of two credits
oh my god wait so when did you go to
college again yeah so I wonder you so I
went to college I was 16 my first year
of college but then I was 19
yeah so I then I took I took I took
extra semester graduate because I
switched majors late to CIC
okay and then in do you have any tips
for college you know for like studying
sweetie we can just study a lot to get
to college like SATs and stuff I studied
some presages but no I wasn't very
motivated I was like ever motivated like
joining a college years um I think I
like sophomore year and up but like
freshman year I really [ __ ] up like I
got I got like that everyone really low
GPA Oh like like sub sub 1 yes that's
why cumulative like I think you told me
by yeah yeah yeah so like that first
year first semester I was at a certain
school like a better school and then I
did really badly because I didn't know
how to study here and that transfer to
that like no name to Bart's call right
yeah ok we sub 1 does that mean you felt
like most I got like I got like F
Santini's perhaps to see myosins like
basically I didn't go to class it wasn't
that like 1 to class thought he didn't
like did bad like I just like I didn't
know Frank depressed or something I just
did
yeah you know why it's because you were
too young
do you want to know I honestly yeah
probably I wasn't I wasn't ready we're
formally mature pre college I'm gonna
fight I think I met a girl that was also
16 years old when she started first year
and I could tell that she was like a
much like emotionally immature yeah and
because of that I think she made a lot
of like dumb decisions like prematurely
saying like oh this is what I want to do
blah blah blah and then when things
don't work out she freaks out why
because during your whole high school
you were be small right you know you
could do everything yeah yeah I wasn't
know I wasn't ready I know yeah yeah you
know what's wrong Society now they
people forget to deal with being bored
forget to do things yeah they don't know
how to deal with being bored you know
and then because of that they had these
like advanced or like these skip grading
[ __ ] that doesn't that this in like way
I I don't see the connection between
like I was with you were part of that
and then you jumped to this like ap like
okay [ __ ] naughty people like just
skipping grades yeah you know I mean
like like for example oh you're saying
you know you're great three and you're
smarter than everyone else then then you
go dry or whatever they're but back then
we didn't we didn't have these like ap
[ __ ] right people just you know just
learn at the same pace as everyone all
right but you could do something for
boredom you just stay in a class you
think of [ __ ] right yeah yeah that's
true I think I think I think that's new
and it was yesterday
oh yeah studying in general yeah yes I
didn't I didn't study at all freshman
year and generally like I I never really
became a good study ER until like like
maybe like one year out of college and
like and then like year after college
oh it's nice so I that wasn't a good
student in college it's like my
cumulative GPA even in my new school was
like just under three yeah that's okay
what is that in terms of letter grades I
like a be like if yeah yeah
and so like and I had I got like decent
grades and my CS classes and my like
philosophy classes but basically when I
didn't care about a class I just like
didn't do [ __ ] for it but
I think that's kind of always been like
my mo like if I really care about
something I go like 100% like all in um
but if I don't then I don't know but
yeah you go and then yeah I guess I
guess the thing that I want to know more
is like you know how do you prevent
procrastination how do you you know
study for like long peers yeah and keep
being motivated yeah yeah so I'm not I
still procrastinate but I have like I
went through this big like
self-improvement phase and so yeah if
like really read a lot about how to not
procrastinate so there's this like
there's a famous paper that has this
like equation of procrastination and it
basically says like yeah so there's like
there's like four four elements of
across the nation and basically like one
element is expect expect expectancy and
basically it means like it's expecting
expectancy is low like you don't think
it's gonna happen or like what do you
mean like basically don't you might
procrastinate something because you
don't think you're gonna do well so it's
like you don't think it okay so it
doesn't even matter
yeah yeah I don't think to Lee Cole I'm
not gonna cry oh my god I expectancy
means like you know a good confidence
gonna go well or something like that
I might mess up with it but they said
for a moment did I know that woman it's
like the reward and then know that
elements like like attention and then
debase the ideas like you want to like
raise a Quebec expectancy and like
decrease attention like attention dick
distraction and like increase the reward
and so there's there's just like famous
like flow chart of like ways you can
like do that which is a flow chart while
it's like this like like graph thing no
I'll find it like but basically yeah
there's a bunch of different techniques
like I mentioned I don't break the chain
and then another one is it's gone up we
explained that don't break the chain
since it's gonna be a different video
yeah so don't break the chain is
basically like you try to do whatever
you want to do for
every day and then as you do it for that
day you just like make a mark of it and
then like if you imagine like a big
calendar you basically want to build up
a chain of like X's marks and then as a
chain goes up it becomes like more and
more like there's like inertia or like
momentum like you don't want to break it
as it gets longer you just want to keep
it going
right there's no fat yeah I've been
trying it again like a streak yeah I've
been trying to no fat yeah for a while
yeah
why should I guess the chain it's just
like the idea of like a streak yes like
snap-snap streak right but it came about
before all that but anyway then the I
know their ideas like pompadours
where you basically just try to dude
high five man I heard that word yeah
like I don't know what it is but I see
people making videos of that yeah where
did you study and people watch that [ __ ]
yeah so yeah by doing nothing anyways
Pomodoro I guess is the initial meaning
is I guess like some kind of like timer
like tomato timer thing okay yeah and so
basically you just set it and you work
for 25 minutes and then you take a
five-minute break you repeat it's
literally all it is but the reason why
it works is because Optima destination
happens because like you can't get
started or you don't know where to get
started
so like or it's intimidating right so
it's a lot more intimidating to like
think about studying for four hours then
is to think about just let's just do 25
minutes right God and so it's like it's
basically just about breaking it down
that makes sense yeah I think starting
is the hardest yeah like even for videos
or anything okay so I've been unemployed
for a while yeah and that holy [ __ ] I
told myself I was like oh I'm gonna make
videos I'm gonna do all that I didn't do
anything you know and and I didn't do
anything with my time either because
like it's just so hard like starting
right and I think that's the hardest
part but then once you get started it
the flow is a lot exactly yeah that's
nothing right like flow that's a big I
think you can get into a state of flow
so flow is basically just like like
you're totally immersed you don't notice
time passing and like you begin to say
flow is basically impossible to be like
distracted or to like procrastinate like
because you're just like totally in the
moment like like mindfulness like 100%
attention and so you can get to that
state by like gamification
by you know being intrinsically
interested in like the journey then the
help spot oh that makes sense
I was in the flow when I was drawing
actually there's one thing that I want
to talk about for procrastination
I always procrastinate by procrastinate
by doing other stuff that's productive
yeah so actually that's a that's
actually a technique it's called
structured procrastination basically the
imagine a list of things you like have
to do or I want to do then you think
about like so the thing at the top is
like something you really need to do but
you don't want to do it but there's
something else right below it that's
like also pretty important but you what
you don't want to do it like the amount
to what you don't want to do it isn't as
high as the first one so you can
procrastinate the first one we're in
second one right yeah and so eventually
as long as the first one isn't like
super important right then still yeah
you're still doing something up yeah
yeah it's like yeah that makes a lot I
guess yeah that's pretty cool
I remember wait what was my
procrastination thing like it's probably
like Oh back then he was like oh I don't
want to work on paper like that Facebook
yeah I'm [ __ ]
yeah and then instead I make videos
videos yeah I think that's why I was so
for that and then when I need to make
videos because it becomes like a chore
it's like not yeah yeah and then I think
and then I did laundry I just paint up
or yeah yeah that's the thing yeah yeah
but the issue is that is whenever
there's like the top priority thing
right really important yeah I have to do
it but yeah but then again if it's
really that important and there's a
timeline I'm sorry there's like a
deadline uh-huh
I usually do pretty well right before
the deadline yeah I know me too I think
yeah that's another thing it's like like
a force the desperation yeah but it's
like it's also I can risk it because so
one thing I've noticed personally is
that like as I've voted up the history
of doing stuff right before a deadline
and as I've built up a history of
successfully doing the margin becomes
smaller because like a brain my brain is
like dude there's no need to panic I've
done this five minutes like let's just
do four minutes this time right and
eventually it's gonna crash eventually
it's not gonna work anymore yeah you
need to like trick of brain and saying
like don't be that confident yes five
the time or like yeah I guess are you
just like Al and the next time yeah yeah
and then but the issue at work I feel
like I feel like I work a lot of
deadlines are actually like soft
deadline self-imposed it ya know and I
even self-imposed even worse than that
like imagine a p.m. tell you the arbiter
tells you that they have a margin of
error also they actually know that you
might you know and then I don't know
I've learned to be like he's doin lazy
at work but without the negative
consequences sometimes you know it's a
pushing back pushing back ya know but
that's a good that's a good skill to
yeah I'm pushing back cool cool cool